you you're Ned Stark's bastard aren't
you did I offend you sorry technically
speaking a bastard is is just any child
born out of wedlock who did it stuck
he's my father
ladies stock is an austrial mother
making you a bastard
medieval societies including Westeros
tended to be more religious than our
modern society more superstitious in
some ways they do nothing about genetics
or DNA but they had their own version of
it which is blood blood will tell just
the fastest the bastard of Robert of the
house Baratheon the grand maker of
bastards in the Seven Kingdoms is Robert
Baratheon we see about four of them
being murdered in the opening episode of
season two when Joffrey sends forth is
people to find them the one who gets
away from that slaughter of the
innocents of course is Andrew who is one
of Roberts older bastards and Andrea
looks very much like the young Robert
something in Ned recognizes divinity
lays eyes on Gendry find anything King
Robert's bastard soon Westeros of course
is a very strong class structure the
small folk as they're called they
probably produce just as many bastards
if not more as the noble classes but
they don't have any surnames and here we
have Bronn son of
you wouldn't know it the noble houses do
have their names and when they produce
bastards they can't have his father's
name so they give him a bastard name
very simple declarative names that
basically tell you this person has noble
blood in them but their bastard boys
Rebecca flow blue and it differs from
region to region in the North you have
snow in the Vale of Arryn it's stone and
the Riverlands it's rivers and the
western lands it's Hill Iron Islands
it's pike and to reach its flowers in
the area around King's Landing the name
waters has been used in the Stormlands
and storm and in Dorne it's sand I don't
believe you have met Ellaria this is the
Lord hand Tywin Lannister and Cersei
Lannister the Queen Regent milady
can't say I've ever met a sand before
Dorne is a very different culture from
the rest of Westeros it's more
hedonistic approach to life they take in
many ways a more relaxed approach to
life bastards are born of passion aren't
they we don't despise them in Dorne know
how tolerant of you the Dornish have
different customs quite a few different
customs one of which is just that
bastards aren't looked down upon in the
way that they are and the other six
kingdoms people everywhere have their
differences in some places the highborn
frown upon those of low birth you're a
bastard you're nothing here whereas in
Dorne
we have loads of bastards I'm surrounded
by them them up that's my family I'm one
to have 10,000 brothers and sisters and
I'm not quite sure what to call you
ilaria works for everyone knows
hilarious and might be a bastard but
it's quite permissible for her to be the
mother of a Prince's babies and no one
really thinks twice about this what do
you do with a bastard child every house
does something different some will raise
the bastard child as a member to family
but the bastard child has no inheritance
rights a bastard boy with nothing to
inherit off to join the Ancient Order of
the Nights Watch lot of bastards do
gravitate to the wall Jon Snow is not
the only one up there by any means but
they've always welcomed on the wall no
bastard was ever refused to see that
bastards can rise their two officers and
command some of you bear the names of
proud houses others only bastard names
or no names that's all
Galit Aryan society not completely by
any means it still tends to favor the
sons of wards and the sons of Great
Houses
Lord snow here grew up in the castle
spitting down on the likes of you you
have John snow of course it was probably
the most famous bastard in the in the
story he's right up front the the
bastard of Winterfell I think John did
have a choice to join us what you know
he actively chose he wants the Nights
Watch to emulate his uncle Benjen and
offensively I think in his head to lead
he wants to lead them when John first
came to Castle black he was maybe a
little bit spoiled he was a tough kid
and he was a kid we'd never back down
from a fight by the same time he grew up
in a castle he grew up with very
high-class people and even if he was a
bastard himself his best friend was Robb
Stark and he was raised by Ned Stark and
he ended up driving to Castle black and
becoming a leader for the first time
none of that would have come to pass and
none of that would have been the way it
was if Jon Snow felt that he belonged in
Winterfell Jon Snow's second-class
citizenship and Ramsay Snow's
second-class citizenship I mean these
are major kind of driving forces in the
story father welcome home
Walda this is Ramsay snow my bastard
Ramsay snow is a bastard son of Roose
Bolton Ramsay grew up knowing he was a
Lord's son but completely disinherited
not part of the castle life just living
with his mother but when rusev all the
son died he was all that Roose had left
so there's a tremendous amount of anger
and resentment Ramsay has a problematic
relationship with his father
I think Psychopaths often have
problematic relationships with their
father my mother taught me not both
stones and ripples but my father told me
well they had but his main goal in his
life would be to be given the
acknowledgement respect of his father
that he's been denied as a bastard his
entire life he hates being busted and he
wants to be legitimate and he wants to
kind of impress his father that's the
only thing I think that he wants more
than just inflicting pain on people the
relationship between ruse and Ramsay is
in some way
a dark counterpoint to the relation
between Ned Stark and Jon Snow in both
cases a noble father with a bastard son
John and Ramsay are literally the
opposite to each other you know John's
very noble and honorable and found these
none of those things Roose himself is a
cold and calculating man a dispassionate
man I play the far too much trust in you
what your treatment of the bastard son
is is very different
Ned keeps job snow at Winterfell and
he's raised with Robb and brand he's
thrilled practical purposes he's one of
Ned's sons you ought to stop you might
not have my name you have my blood
Ramsay gets nothing from Roose the
flayed man is on our balance my bonus
not yours you're not a boat in your snow
there's also some analogues here to the
Tyrion titling relationship the hell do
you know about being a busted old
wharves are bastards in their father's
eyes let me give you some advice bastard
never forget what you are the rest of
the world would not wear it like armor
and it can never be used to hurt you
you